so Judy my first question is for you
because I was reading a whole lot about
how you passed on many pitches to adapt
this book to screen so what was it about
Kelly's take on the material that set it
apart from all the pictures you've heard
in the past well it was Kelly's
incredible letter that she wrote to me
um and in in that email she told me that
she had by the end she saved it for the
end I think and by the way you know I
wrote and directed a movie called The
Edge of Seventeen and I'm like wait what
I've seen that movie I love that movie
so this is the first time that someone
came to me with these credentials you
know something I could actually see and
say I love this and this is a this is a
good person and she came with James L
Brooks and they came to visit me and it
was wonderful and we knew we were going
to work together edge of 17 is a pretty
good calling card right there I'll say
it was a great calling it was the
calling card oh yes
said Kelly for you I was reading a
little bit about how you had been
working on the script for this for about
a year so I was wondering what would you
say is the biggest difference between
draft one and what we see on screen now
in the finished film um
a lot that's
what I would say a lot because I
remember it all the different drafts
yeah it was because it was uh you know
you you find it and you wrestle with it
and it's a lot of I think the first
draft is sort of you sort of put
everything including the kitchen sink in
and then you start to take pieces out
and shape it I mean it's really the the
process is really
um
um I don't know when where you find it
you find the movie over the course of
over the course of each process casting
you know editing
um all of it
and she found it was there any
particular game changing moment in terms
of finding it that you could share with
us no matter what part of the process
it's in hmm
um gosh
um you know I just have to say there
were certain moments that we filmed on
set that just felt like oh that this is
so exciting that's the spirit of the
movie
um one of them was actually when
Margaret goes into her room and puts on
a pad for the first time like there's
just something about seeing that
intimate moment that something that
should be something we've seen before
but I as a 42 year old woman have
actually never seen another human being
put a pad in their underwear and walk
around so there's something about that
that just felt
um I don't know there's something
electrifying about it and
um that felt like okay we're doing Judy
Bloom you know but for me it was the
moment with Laura danker and Margaret
realizes
that she hasn't been fair to this girl
and she chases her and says Laura wait
wait and Laura goes into a church and
Margaret follows her into the church and
Margaret goes into a confessional to see
what it's like and it's almost like
she's saying are you there God and
she doesn't know what's going to happen
and the priest says yes my child
and it's like oh like this is so
wonderful there's so many moments that
stick out in my head now that you're
bringing up that I want to ask about
I'll Judy I'll ask you a little more
broadly even having written this book
yourself was there any part of the story
that became stronger than you ever could
have imagined when you saw it on screen
something that gave like even you a
greater appreciation for an element of
your own book completely completely
because Kelly wrote the mother Kelly
wrote Barbara Simons and and then Rachel
McAdams plays her in such a way that is
so wonderful that I say I want to come
back in my next life and be a mother
like the mother that Kelly wrote and
Rachel plays in this movie so there's so
much you know about that because a movie
is different than a book even if it's
the whole book and it is but you get to
see these characters you get to see them
as real people with that in mind Kelly
so you've now explored you know a
coming-of-age scenario in the pre-teen
Years also in high school in the future
are there any other stages of life where
you'd be most eager to explore the
coming of age experience in a film
because you do kind of do it here in
addition to Margaret with her mother and
her grandmother and I feel like we kind
of boxed the idea of you know a
coming-of-age story into kids and kids
only which is not the case yes no I I
think that you're so right I feel like
you can come of age at any age and I
feel like I'm constantly on that Journey
you know what I mean every time I have
to step up and and you know and embody
some new role or do something that's
uncomfortable I I feel like an awkward
12 year old all over again
um so yeah uh I don't know I don't know
but I definitely I there's something
about this particular period of life
that always
um I don't know it was fascinating to me
I I wonder like why do you write about
it do you know because it's what came
naturally and
um and it was right there I you know
scratched the surface and the 12 year
old was there yes maybe yes maybe you
have to go a little deeper right now
um
I think you know writing is that way
it's it's what comes naturally what you
want to do what your most attracted to
you can never do too much because each
one is so different
each and coming of age is coming of age
at any age
I'm here for it no matter what age you
explore next I wanted to ask a question
based on a quote that I read of Judy's
and our production notes that really
stood out to me Judy you were talking a
little bit about the idea of becoming an
author and how your New York Times book
review had influenced you and I think
the the quote was something like it was
the first time that you had allowed
yourself to think like maybe I could do
this maybe I could become an author so
Kelly for you I wanted to apply that to
becoming a director is there anything
you experienced that finally made you
think like maybe I can do this oh gosh
that's such a good question
oh you know I I have to say
um you know jumping into the director's
chair is such a it's such a daunting
thing that you actually kind of don't
know until you get there you know and
then it's just sink or swim
um but I knew that I cared I cared
desperately about all the details and I
knew that that was the job of the
director was to you know was to make
sure all of those were right and and I'm
I'm definitely obsessive about those so
I knew at the very least I could bring
an obsessiveness you know I feel like
that's the only way like you could
actually swim in this industry it's
either obsessive or Nothing at All yes
totally thank you both for your time
today huge congratulations on the film
thank you so much thank you so much